hello everyone and welcome to today's
keynote presentation mass spectrometry
approaches for the single cell chemical
characterization of the brain presented
by dr. Jonathan sweet lay director
school of chemical sciences University
of Illinois at urbana-champaign
I am execute eras of lab roots and I
will be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
libraries labyrinth is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars now before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at anytime you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on this screen our speaker will
respond to your questions via email and
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the ask
a question box to let us know that
you're having a problem this
presentation is education on thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
sweet ler I will now turn the
presentation over to him well thank you
very much it's a pleasure to be here
today I'm going to be as mentioned
talking to you about some of the
approaches that we use within a research
group to measure the chemical content of
individual cells using a range of mass
spectrometry approaches first question
you may ask is why single cells and why
discovery based single cell approaches I
want to distinguish mass spectrometry
approaches where it's untargeted and you
actually measure the content of
particular classes of molecules in a
cell as distinct say from fluorescence
microscopy where you can use an antibody
and tag a particular analyte of interest
this these approaches I'll be describing
are untargeted so why would we want to
do single-cell measurements I asked this
question because it's important to
realize a single-cell chemical measure
is actually harder than the measurement
of a beaker full of material and so if
you're not gaining something it's not
worth the effort
so the number one reason is to discover
something about cell heterogeneity that
is how cells are different from each
other either in health or disease and
examples of this would be for example
cancer or disease where a few cells have
a problem in any cells spread another
example is developmental biology where a
single egg divides and becomes an entire
organism today we'll be talking mostly
about single cell heterogeneity within
the brain and you'll see several slides
on that introducing the topic one of the
reasons for doing this is that if a
unusual cell may have unusual chemistry
for example you can imagine that if one
in a thousand cells have a particular
enzyme they'll have a different
chemistry than the other 999 cells
surrounding them and it's easier to
study that chemistry had a high
concentration in the cell of interest
during this talk we're gonna really be
talking about how to isolate the cell
how to prepare the cell with separations
and extraction and finally detection and
hopefully that'll become more clear as
we move ahead so let's move to
neuroscience a little bit about why we
would do this and so this slide shows
several images starting out at the
entire brain down to scattered networks
of neurons even down to a single synapse
and you can see the sources in these
images but in this particular case we
have cells that are connected by wires
these are the axons within the brain and
the electrical activity is shown by
glowing bars the important thing to
realize is there's looks like a lot of
empty space between these cells
that's not empty space that's filled
with other types of cells in your brain
there would be a ligand tender sites or
astrocytes or microglia or even red
blood cells so if you were to take a
microliter of a mouse brain or look at a
microliter of a human brain most of the
cells in that microliter would not be
neurons so if you wanted to understand
what's in a neuron you would actually
have to somehow select the neurons and
that's another reason to do single cell
measurements so this slide highlights
the chemical
complexity of a single cell this slide
was given to me by Leena and morose at
the University of Florida and it's
basically talking you know it really
shows that spatial heterogeneity of a
neuron but I also wanted to point out
that according to lipid maps there's
about 20,000 different chemical entities
that are lipid related in a neuron or at
least in the brain 20,000 or so
different metabolites that would be
coming from you know the human mental
alone project and a couple hundred
thousand different proteins including
Protea forms that is a particular post
translational modifications on those
proteins now there's no one approach
that allows us to measure all of that
but we're discovering as we actually
apply mass spectrometry to single-cell
measurements that we're discovering a
lot of new chemicals and molecular
entities within the brain and so today's
talk will be really trying to understand
this chemical diversity within the cells
of the brain I this talk is not on the
different types or different flavors of
mass spectrometry my group you has about
seven instruments but if you will look
around there's many different commercial
instruments vendors of mass
spectrometers we happen to use a lot of
Brooker but other instruments would work
and the center of this picture is an old
ABI q-star that we modified by adding a
C 60 iron gun to make it into a
secondary ion mass spectrometer the
reason you need to know a little bit
about this is each mass spectrometer
gives you a different part of the
chemical complexity of the of the brain
so if you use a Sims instrument for
example you see a subset of the
molecules maybe if you use a kyouto off
or a maldi-tof you see others and so
everyone doesn't have to be an expert on
these instruments but the different mass
analyzers selected and the front end in
front of the instruments will tell us
which part of that chemical complexity
we can measure and so as it says here
dealing with the chemical complex it
requires really high quality instruments
the other way which is really what this
talk is on is that if you want to
understand the chemistry of the brain
you can simplify the trillions of
connections and make it simpler this law
kind of really you know really
highlights everything from a
space-filling model of a honeybee bright
so you might study the honeybee to
understand how a nurse can become a
forager or a forager can become a nurse
and we've worked on those with
collaborators such as Gene Robinson to a
brain slice with about a million cells
also to a neural network and then if you
look at this neural network in the
center you will see several neurons and
their connections between them and as a
scientists we might want to know what
molecules are there that's the chemistry
where they are spatial information are
they in a cell soma and are in a process
and when they're there it turns out
there is no measurement approach that
can give us chemistry spatial and
temporal information at the level we
want and so there's always compromises
and during this talk I'll try to go over
some of those compromises so that we can
actually get the information from this
quite type of cells and then lastly you
see one picture of a hippocampal neuron
and it again is a very complex structure
now chemical measurements are actually
not new you know it depends on how you
want to define it but I would claim that
the first single-cell measurements of
cells really date back to the discovery
the microscope so Hooke early and Hoek
and to be honest when it comes to the
brain the microscopist came first so
they named the cell types they got to
name him star-shaped cells or stellate
cells or pyramid shells pyramidal cells
and it wasn't until really you know the
mid last century the 1950s 60s 70s that
we started to understand more about the
chemistry of these cells and so now we
have cells that have dopamine I mean you
may know that dopamine is the reward
molecule so dopaminergic cells serotonin
related to depression serotonergic cells
and then the last 20 to 30 years I
highlighted here with some of the work
of Jim Jorgenson or mark white men or
Jim ever why'd that really a pioneered
fast more complex measurements of single
cells and I'll show you now from the
1990s to what we can do in the year 2018
so the tried and true approach for
single cell measurements is you somehow
isolate a cell so
showing up the the little box on the top
is the cell of interest it happens to be
green you can isolate that if you are
very shown here with tweezers if you
actually have steady hands and then you
can measure that with the technique I'll
show you that in the next few slides
called capillary electrophoresis or
liquid chromatography you get separated
bands you enter it into the mass
spectrometer you get fractions that you
can quantify and identify you can use
micro fluidics and they're a little
faster all of these techniques require
some way of selecting the cell and so
the question becomes how do we do that
so here's just a simple example this is
some work from my group and this is out
from a sea slug of lychee californica
and it happens to be a sea slug that
neuroscientist have used for a long time
with Eric Kandel at when the Nobel Prize
for learning and memory one of the cells
in the abdominal ganglia is green and
it's green because we stained it with a
green dye saying that's the cell of
interest sometimes we've had
collaborators inject dye into one cell
in an organism and then we isolate that
cell and what we do then website let me
just click through this and okay there
we go we then separate the contents in
using capillary electrophoresis and so
here we have capillary electrophoresis
it's a separation mode many people are
familiar with it if you're not it's like
liquid chromatography you'll be hearing
other talks during this event on liquid
chromatography but the idea is you
inject the cell in one side the chemical
constituents migrate out the other end
and Sonne shown here is a very simple
laboratory constructed device we put the
cell in the sample vial remove the
capillary to this background electrolyte
we apply 20,000 volts and that material
migrants through the capillary and has
entered no electric raid into our mass
spectrometer and when we do that we can
get a catholic to freeze this mass
spectra this is kind of a heroic example
so most of you know that a fruit fly is
a is fairly small his brain is on the
order of a nano liter
I had a visiting postdoc Susie Newport
from Germany and she's now at Yana
Germany but she was able to using
genetic approaches labeled particular
cells show
here on green she could isolate one of
those cells injected into the end of
this capillary electrophoresis capillary
and then shown in the center is a c-e-o
after fara gram of different bands and
peak 5 and 6 are clearly labeled as
October mean it's a water loss so it
comes out twice and there's the mass
spectra so we can say the cell that she
isolated has October mean in it and we
get about a hundred or so contents
compounds in each individual cell even
when the cell is 5 microns and so this
is actually on the order of about a Pico
liter volume and so a conventional
electrospray instrument has the detect
ability to detect what's in a cell in a
brain as small as a fruit fly if you
don't drink coffee if you can isolate
the cell and inject it into the system
some of you might say I'm not interested
in fruit flies here's an example from
mammals and this is showing you a
different way of doing some work this
was actually we published this in 2014
and what we use is the patch clamp
sampling now patch clamp sampling is an
approach that are when they are and the
southland came up with they won the
Nobel Prize for this approach in the
early 90s and you can see a cell where
they have a pipette that's patched onto
it and they use this approach to measure
the electric physiology of the cell
shown here is a spontaneous activity of
a ceramic reticular neuron from a rat
and while they're measuring this they
all have access to the cytoplasm so they
can actually where we can actually suck
up about 20 or 30% maybe a people liter
of solution from this cell into this
capillary now we have the intracellular
contents and we can now measure them and
so I think this is the last example that
I'll show you of this sort of
measurement directly and these are sort
of heroic in measurements because you
have to patch onto the cell make sure
it's a good patch you can record the
electrical activity shown on the left
for four different cells we have a
fluorophore in the patch pipette so we
inject a little N and we can see the
whole cells shown here and on the right
are the electropherograms and we can
detect about a hundred compounds in each
individual cell now if you took a
million cells and did this you would
probably detect a thousand compounds and
so by going to the single cell level we
have a low through
we're detecting fewer compounds but
we're getting information for example on
flem ik reticular neurons that are
active or owing at spontaneously active
or those that are active for example
only when he inject current so you get a
lot of information and the bottom trace
is actually when we patched on to an
astrocyte this is some work in this
publication in analytical chemistry that
was done in collaboration with lee cox
as well as our group so this allows us
to very carefully select cells and
measure them for small molecules I want
to move now to neuropeptides
neuropeptides
our gene products and so they come from
DNA their to RNA to a protein and they
basically a neuropeptide Pro hormone
gene makes a prohormone the problem from
a measurement science point of view is
this Pro hormone has so many
modifications to it that even knowing
that a particular Pro hormones such as
neuropeptide Y Pro hormone or substance
P or pom C is made you can't know the
final product the other reason these are
important is they actually modify
behaviors there's a couple quotes from
lots of people that will say they
determine when you're hungry when you're
attracted in others and so I there's a
quote here from etro Stevens made that
they help determine you know several of
the deadly sins and this is just
pointing out that neuro peptides are
important the reason we have to measure
them is shown in this slide and if you
if you don't like the slide there's only
I think this is the only one like it
this is a biochemical way of
representing a prohormone as a long bar
with lots of colors and these colors
represent cleavage project products into
peptides one gene product and all these
bars on the bottom represent different
peptides from that gene that are made in
the cell and in this particular
prohormone is from again Aplysia
californica that sea slug we study
learning and memory and the B and C
chain are the DNA chain form insulin
this D peptide as Amma dated this is
palma carboxylated this one forms pyro
glue if you wanna know the bioactive
peptides you have to measure those
chemical forms and that's where mass
promontory comes in as one more bit of
history neuropeptides have been
characterized since the 1960s and 70s
and ghulam UNS Nobel prize-winning
address about thyroid releasing hormone
or CRH he makes this comment that they
needed several million sheep hypo-thala
my to collect enough material to
characterize and so what I'll be showing
you in the next few slides instead of
several million brains you can do this
on a single cell again one more example
this is Victor Mott who characterized a
lot of the mammalian peptides in the gut
of mammals shown here is one of the
samples being delivered it's literally
tons of pig intestines and it wasn't
very pleasant to extract neuro peptides
from tons of sheep and in this case pig
intestines to get a few milligrams that
you could characterize and so when I
show you that you can work at a single
cell you know it tells you cell
heterogeneity but it also it makes the
samples a lot better so a lot easier to
work with this slide is sort of
highlighted in the upper right it's a
single my group drew this it's a single
cell getting hit by a laser I sort of
think it looks like maybe you know Star
Wars and Jabba the Hutt getting hit by a
laser or something but this is supposed
to be showing a cell with a laser and
you can see the molecules flying out
into the mass spectrometer what we
really have here is we isolate the cell
of interest we put it on a target or
even we can cell culture it and there's
a cell we put a matrix around it we
shine it on a laser the matrix explodes
and we get a mass spectra of all the
peptides in that cell again that type of
measurement has been around for a while
this is a slide from Franz Hillen camp
he was the inventor of MALDI he shared
several of these slides with me before
he passed away a few years ago and this
is some work he did in 1970s with laser
desorption before moldy existed and so
the idea behind this is old but the
information contact content is really
increased so we label here's an example
is sort of a throughput that we and
other groups do there's a dark cell here
if in the middle trace you see a group
of cells and one is missing the orange
arrow points to the missing cell and
that missing cell the spectra is on the
bottom and if we know what peptides are
in that
and we know what that cell does in this
particular case it activates the feeding
network in this creature we can guess a
little bit about what that cell does so
we've discovered in different animals
ranging from mammals to sea slugs
literally over a thousand brain peptides
but in about a hundred cases we know
something about their function because
we know what the cell did the you know
you might ask how sensitive this
approach is and so shown here is you
know as a measurement we've done where
we actually took angiotensin one peptide
and applied it to a clean slide using a
chemical spotter and it shows here sixty
femto mows down to three femto moles in
the first trace 600 atomos down to about
thirty in the bottom one is six animals
down to about three hundred Zepto moles
that's three hundred times ten to the
minus twenty-one moles and everywhere
there's a spot we see a dot our
detection limits of angiotensin on a
clean trace are actually under three
hundreds after moles and on a good day
when the humidity is right it's better
than a hundred s after moles the reason
this is important is using a commercial
in this case Brooker Ultraflex stream
but it would work with other instruments
we can detect easily what's in a couple
dense core vesicles easily what's in a
cell if we don't have the problems of
sampling and so single-cell measurements
are feasible and improvements really
have to be in the sampling area the mass
spectrometers have sufficient
sensitivity and detect ability to work
at the single cell level so what I want
to show you now is how to make this
high-throughput because the approaches I
showed you with patch clamp or isolating
a cell are fantastic but they take
somebody who's trained at recognizing
what cell to analyze so mass cytometry
is a great technique that allows you to
use antibodies that attack things and
actually then do this in a very high
throughput area I'm not gonna be talking
about that I'm gonna be talking about
dissociation and then using this
optically guided approach in between
here is microarrays from mass
spectrometry this is a really elegant
approach that there's an OB lab
pioneered and you can actually buy these
at Sigma and other places and they have
a bunch of microarrays and you can put
randomly one two or three cells in and
you probe them
that works we're you know you have to
tailor the these arrays to the cell size
what we do instead is scatter the cells
on a microscope slide and a saya so let
me show you how that works this is an
example of a group of cells scattered on
slide and you can see some cells labeled
with axons and other debris and if we
did mass spec imaging with you know
scanning across an irregular pattern the
red dots represent the laser once in a
while we hit a cell maybe twice but
instead of using that approach this
doesn't work we published in 2015 we
just shine the laser at the cells and if
you can target the laser it's much
faster so here's how we do it we take
our sample we actually take a microscope
slide first and prepare it by adding a
bunch of laser shots to make fiducial
marks now when we take the slide in and
out we can line those up and we know
where we're looking we scatter our cells
on the slide then we spray our Waldie
matrix on it with an air gun and now we
have the laser that are probing it and
you get the mass spectra and then you
can do you know informatics to find out
the cell population shown here is two
populations a gray and a dark one so let
me show you some real data not within
this case eight cells but here we have
about 10,000 rat pituitary cells
scattered on a slide we made the cells
fluorescent by adding a nuclear stain in
this case a host dye we get little dots
wherever there's a cell we image it with
the fluorescence microscope we figure
out their locations and with our laser
we can target those and we sometimes
have cells that are too close together
we throw those out so maybe you get five
or six thousand cells from these 10,000
and then we analyze that shown here is
principal component analysis looking to
group these cells and the cells here
have a different specter than here and
so we're able to do in this way tens of
thousands of cells and look for their
peptides let me give you an example that
maybe is more understandable and that's
an islet and islets a good example
because most people know they should
have alpha beta gamma and Delta cells
that have glucagon or insulin or pink
hormone so we tried this with eyelets
from a rodent and we took eyelets both
from the dorsal and the ventral pancreas
and when we do that and then assay over
a thousand cells from four different
eyelets from four animals our principal
component analysis automatically
segregates these by the presence of a
glucagon and insulin and pancreatic
hormone into alpha beta and gamma and
Delta cells and shown here you just see
how the separation that has a very clean
separation and from that the dorsal or
ventral you can see the fraction of
cells that were alpha beta gamma or
Delta and we got about six 1,700 cells
of each type we can easily do more but
this is a good example we published this
just another year and a half ago you can
dig deeper into the data this is now
just looking at the pancreatic hormone
cells and again one of those biochemical
ways of showing a prohormone and then
you cleave here at a signal peptide you
cleave here at a basic site at k our
site there is pancreatic hormone it has
a mass to charge of $43.99 but it turns
out here is a die basic site that has an
arginine arginine RR site and if that
were to be cleaved also you'll get a
peptide that weighed 1296 this peptide
was presumed to be made by a few groups
they studied it and discovered that this
peptide actually binds to one of the
nura peptide for receptors in an islet
but then when they measured it they said
it wasn't there we in the ventral versus
dorsal this is a histogram of that
peptide at 1296 representing the
cleavage of the arginine our journey we
found a few cells in the ventral side
that have lots of this peptide cleaved
and almost all the rest have none so
five or six cells have some to have a
lot and you see scattered a few cells
evidently have different processing
enzymes and make different products so
these cells are making a different
peptide that was already known to be
bioactive and there you go it has a
chance to see unusual processing so
here's a one slide interlude of going
back to some of our data from about 15
years ago and I'll explain why I'm
showing you this here this is some work
we did in the about the year 2001 we
published it in 2002 where we
used a radioactive cytochrome C protein
put it on the MALDI target and then if
you just move the target in and out of
the instrument there's no change but if
you take that and do mass spectrometry
even after 500 laser shots the signaling
goes down about 20% and even after a
thousand you know it goes down thirty or
so percent so if we only use a couple
hundred shots we have most of the
material still there so this allows us
to do the following and this is
important by the way this is using my
chrome and asked the software that if
you look at this it's a it's a
publication from last year you can
download this software and we actually
have ways of using it from most
different commercial vendors and this is
a cell in this case lipids
there's the cell we hit it and we do
mass spectrometry with the time of
flight instrument in a resolution of
about 11,000 and there's some of the
lipids in that cell we can take the
slide out walk to a new building put it
in a solar X instrument and we get about
a hundred eighty thousand resolution
same cell we don't miss the cells we
couldn't go to a sims instrument for
example on a different cell shown here
we get a different set of Peaks for
different lipids different selection
rules for ionization and then we can do
them all date we can measure a cell
multiple times so now I can combine the
first and the second parts of this talk
this is Catholic to phoresis of them
celled after we did moldy on it this
happens to be a dorsal root ganglia cell
and there it is we made a system that
sucks up the cell and then puts it into
our CG system for Catholic to rhesus
mass spectrometry here it is on an islet
cell these are three Maulvi Tov mass
spectra of three cells I know that their
alpha cells because they have glucagon
you can see the glucagon peak these are
the lipids on the left the glucagon they
don't have pancreatic hormone or insulin
and we can take those exact cells and do
pathway like to freeze a sauna under
showing a few amino acids and
interesting enough if you look out here
the purple band changes a lot the serine
level we actually later on have shown
its d-serine really varies cell to cell
if you want you can look at dopamine in
those cells and so this is now dopamine
in that particular cell this is one of
the first direct chemical measurements
of dopamine in alpha cell and
can do this because we can do repeated
measurements after we published this
last year we were approached by some
local now collaborators and now we're
working on human islets as part of a
merican Diabetes Association visionary
award just want to show you some
unpublished work just very preliminary
weave these are transplant quality human
islets meaning that they isolate them
and some of these are transplanted into
diabetics that need eyelets or they have
a few left over and they'll send to us
the eyelet quality is so so they're
still living but they're different sizes
we can isolate the single cells we can
measure them so these are eyelets from
an individual person and there's four
eyelets shown here this one actually has
just a dot is a different different cell
from a single eyelet there's this eyelet
has very few that as pancreatic has some
out of Staten and this one has a lot if
you go over here the first eyelet that
didn't have much somatostatin has lots
of glucagon and as you can see the last
eyelet actually has lots of insulin
producing cells beta cells so we're
getting a lot of information from
individual cells there's really no other
way to get this and now hopefully we'll
be using this to look at changes in the
distributions of insulin or glucagon or
other peptides in the transition for
example into type one diabetes just one
more example when we were doing that we
actually there's a peptide called ox
into module n' it's a GLP like peptide
and it's normally thought to be an int
arrow endocrine cells in the gut
we found one cell that seemed to have a
lot of them in one of these islet
samples one sample one case I can't say
much about it this is certainly very
preliminary but it really does show you
cell heterogeneity is high just a couple
more examples this is just peptides from
Anantara endocrine cell these are in the
gut and people don't really know too
much about cell heterogeneity these
sense food they sense hormones in the
blood and then they release hormones
that then impact your brain and the
islets and other cells we were contacted
by mya angle store
and her advisor threw his shorts and
said can you measure these and I'll show
you a little bit about this
we tried mass spec imaging this is mass
spec imaging that would be a topic of
another talk from a mouse and antara
endocrine cells were labeled with GFP
you can't really see much with mass spec
imaging we see lots of Peaks but not the
right peptides so here's an example
where I mean just skip to this you can
see individual green cells when we
target those cells we can see
differences in the peptides and here's
one of the better examples this cell for
example as glp-1 and 2py and secretin
out of the thousands of cells present we
get a few cells that have peptides and
we're trying to understand if the
heterogeneity of these cells is quite
high they wanted more cells or
collaborators and so we actually are now
using fax to sort the fluorescent cells
and this is showing you we can sort them
based on the fluorescence of that band
and now this is just one example I think
it's dealing what I'm showing you and
the individual peptide heterogeneity of
antara endocrine cells is really
staggering there's not just nine types
one for each Pro hormone but many of the
cells Express multiple Pro hormones and
we're still trying to understand what
that heterogeneity does but there's
really no other way to get this and even
if you did clustering you would see
different clusters of different groups
of Pro hormones and it's really a
staggering cell heterogeneity so in the
last ten minutes or so I thought I would
just give you a few snippets of other
molecules you might not care about neuro
peptides or neurotransmitters so let's
talk a little bit about lipids and other
molecules using the exact same approach
this is some work we've unpublished work
from our group done by Elizabeth Newman
and what we've done is we've scattered
cells for the rodent cerebellum Anna
began the target we've imaged them with
fluorescence figured out the location in
this case we measured them with an IC R
and we color coordinated those by the
highest intensity lipid and there's a
lot of variability you can do this for
more cells you can do this and now look
at cell size for example the this is
principal component analysis of the
lipids in these cells and each dot
represents an individual cell lipid
profile and the large cells presumably
broke inje neurons because they're
bigger have a very distinct lipid
profile this big blob down here of
individual cells are is probably
heterogeneous because we have astrocytes
oligodendrocytes microglia and other
cells you can actually do this for more
cells this is 30,000 individual
cerebellar cells and I'm not going to
show you 30,000 spectra and again this
is unpublished but we can now start
clustering these into cell types based
on their lipids and in this case looking
at this data carefully we see about 1200
features that have isotopic
distributions that seem to suggest their
lipids and they separated into about a
hundred and sixty ish clusters of lipid
contents this type of information really
is unique and gives us a lot of
information about cell heterogeneity
that hasn't been explored
let me show now to something that was
just published earlier this year this is
with a couple people in the group but
it's the number one author is uh dr.
Fangio who was in my group and just
started at the University of Tennessee
Knoxville so he's been there as a
professor for just a couple months and
he was looking at individual dorsal root
ganglia cells from the rodent spine and
he analyzed the same cell with a low
mass and a high mass protocol and in all
cases even if we don't show them we
actually checked to make sure it was a
single cell and then we see the spectra
and if you look at this a little bit
more detail the low mass has lipid
dimers and trimers as well as a few
peptides and pro hormones or hormones
and the high mass has some of those all
the way up to proteins up to about 15 to
20 kilo daltons and when we do this and
a non targeted way he started to notice
that there was at least three
populations of cells shown here with
different spectral features well can he
make that a little more robust and so
what he has done is he did a cell
correlation he used a covariance matrix
and so basically what cell features are
found together with each other and if
they're positively or negative
correlation they come out in groups and
so the red ones for example or one group
were those Peaks tend to be always found
together the a and B groups for example
have a different set and so here is the
summary on the right where there's
basically you know a little over a
thousand cells or
about a thousand cells and they fall
into three main groups with just a few
in between so on the bottom is the
distribution and it's very cleanly
different chemical entities in these
three cell types there are a few cells
that share mixtures of cell types this
could be because there's actually cells
that have a mixture or I don't know
maybe when we isolated the cells we got
a with a little piece of be stuck on it
and that's why we're seeing this and I
don't know the answer to that but there
are at least three cell types if you
don't like mass spectrometry and you
want to use other approaches I'll show
you just a couple examples this case
using Raman and infrared and this is
with our collaborators Rohit Bhargava
and Martha Jillette at the University of
Illinois at urbana-champaign now we can
see the slide with all the fiducial
marks we blow it up and you see actually
on the lower left the individual spots
that represent the individual cells
bright field on zooming in a little
further you see five cells
marked in yellow or in the bottom you
can see then fluorescence and raman on
the right we don't acquire a mass
spectra of the cells we just hit the
cells but shown here now is a little bit
more and we've done this with primary
hippocampal cells from a rat or a
cultured ct3 cells and then from these
cells we can say how many cell
populations and this is just showing you
a t sneer a distributed stochastic
neighbor and meting and on the lower
case you can see MALDI seems to say
there's three populations Raman a little
less well so but when you combine them
you get a very clear separation of the
three cell types what do you do next
well I would love it if these were for
example neurons astrocytes and
oligodendrocytes how would I know that
well the gold standard is
immunohistochemistry and so actually I
was thinking ahead of slide but we're
now actually starting to do
immunohistochemistry follow up on the
cells after ramen after infra-red after
mass spectrometry and there's a last
slide I really wanted to end with this
if you want to go below a single cell
can you do some cellular profiling of
this you know of the contents and I have
to say here what happens is if you go
from a hundred microliters of sample you
actually can characterize
for example a thousand metabolites if
you go to a single cell maybe it's a
hundred metabolites as you start going
below the number of compounds you see
gets less but you still can do this on
the upper left is an example of MALDI
mass spectrometry of the atrial gland of
Aplysia californica and the upper one is
a dense core vesicle and it has
prohormone processing products peptides
in it and we can measure those the
bottom was is a vesicle from an adjacent
cell it has carbohydrates in it make it
basically slime and we see no peaks
because they're too large to see in this
mass range on the upper right you see an
example of a single cell and a process
and respond on multi matrix of about a
few nano liters each we can see the
lipids and two peptides that are in the
cell soma and transport it to a release
site and lastly in the lower right hand
corner is an example of vitamin E
imaging from a single damaged neuron
using a Sims instrument we built in our
lab and there's a single cell in a
process and there is the cellular
contents of the vitamin A and I don't
know how else you would get this
information vitamin E is deeply buried
in the membrane it would be hard to make
a probe for it so this is some of the
reasons you would do sub cellular
measurements but mostly I've been
telling you today about single cell
measurements
so in conclusion using this approach we
found that in every system we look at
even in beta cells or alpha or gamma
cells in a rat islet we have a lot of
cell heterogeneity and in every system
we've looked at we find unexpected neuro
chemistry or you know endo endocrine
chemistry in all of these cells and so
again these approaches are needed if you
want to study with chemistry occurring
in cells and then lastly I do want to
say it was one of the hard things is the
dynamic range of the brain dorsal root
ganglion neurons go up from a toe to
your you know your brain passing through
the DRG neuron and I don't know any
approach that can work with things that
are large we want to look at
neurotransmission at the millisecond
timeframe but I want to understand why a
dorsal root ganglia stops working after
a decade and these are just you know
I'll say some of the articles that have
come out about single cell measurements
that are kind of overviews you can look
at and I kind of highlight here on the
slide
for recent overviews that are either
fairly general or fairly specific you
can look at that's kind of go over some
of the information that I've been
presenting and thank you very much for
listening to this talk and at this point
I'd be happy to answer any questions and
I do have to end by giving the credit
where credit is due
I've mentioned some of the collaborators
and the group members but I know I've
left some out this slide highlights the
group over the last eight years where
this work was done and at various stages
of winter and summer and April Fool's
Day making fun of my hair the funding
sources as well as some of the
collaborators that helped us in this
work and this work could not have been
done without the support and help from
these individuals thank you very much
thank you dr. sweet Lou for that
informative presentation we will now
start the Q&A portion of the webinar and
we'll address some of the most commonly
asked questions by our viewers if you
have any questions you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question drop-down box located on the
far left of your presentation type your
question into the box that appears on
your screen and click the send button
our speaker will follow with your
questions via email now let's get
started our first question is do the
transcriptomes and metabolome track each
other at the single cell level if not
why don't they that's a great question
and so transcripts are first I'll say
are easy to measure at the single cell
level and so there's a lot of single
cell transcriptomics that transcripts
make proteins some of which are enzymes
and those enzymes are regulated and can
be turned on and off to make molecules
such as serotonin and dopamine and so
they track each other in the sense that
if you don't have the transcripts to
make a particular protein that protein
is likely not present but if you do have
the transcript there's a lot of check
points the cell has and so it may not
actually make the enzyme or the enzyme
may be waiting for something to turn on
and so that the levels of transcripts
versus metabolites in a cell aren't very
correlated for example if the cell has
the transcripts to make serotonin and it
releases a lot it doesn't have much
until it makes more and so this is one
of the reasons if you're interested in
serotonin signaling you really have to
measure the molecules themselves and not
the transcripts and do chemical
differences in individual cells matter
for diseases so that's a question that
NIH and others are desperately trying to
answer so in many cases there are
defects in particular cells and that
gives rise to the disease site but those
defects can be in many cells cancer is
presumed to be a defect that may arise
in just a few cells and then those cells
start dividing and spreading and so in
cancer case the chemical differences in
just a few cells actually give rise to
many cells which then for example give
rise to the tumors in the cancer state
in other cases there's evidence that
even a few mitochondria that go wrong in
a cell with many many mitochondria can
actually leave that cell down to a
disease path so in cases it's been well
studied the answer seems to be yes there
are many cases we don't know enough
about which is why this is an exciting
forefront area we're trying to address
and can you measure proteins such as
receptors at the single cell level okay
so that's an excellent question we study
we study neurotransmitters for examples
such as serotonin and people would say
what about the serotonin receptor and
similarly to that you can imagine neuro
peptides like neuropeptide Y what about
the neuropeptide Y for receptor or
neuropeptide receptors do they track and
the problem is that there are many many
copies of a neuropeptide Y peptide and
there's only a few copies of the
receptors so sometimes for example you
can have a couple hundred thousand
molecules of the peptide and
postsynaptically
there's actually only a couple receptors
and so there's not enough molecules of
receptors for us to characterize at the
single cell level and so no it does not
work unfortunately at this point
at the the single-cell level and so
that's actually one of the the issues
that we've had and so we can measure the
most ball molecules the receptors we
have to measure using other approaches
and can anyone make such measurements if
they have access to a mass spectrometry
facility so that's a really important
point we try to make these measurements
work in a generic way or general way
that anybody can use and so at times we
work with people they prepare samples
for us and we measure it but the micro a
mess with the MALDI toff instrument that
software that approach could be used
anywhere where somebody has access to a
fluorescence microscope the right
imaging system to image the cells
afterward for example and then a
facility that has a the right height of
mass spectrometer and so those should be
generically you know generally available
it might take a little bit of learning
and so our hope is that would be true
for something like Catholic to phoresis
mass spectrometry it would take a little
bit more equipment but some of these
measurements are absolutely doable with
the types of equipment that are found in
many universities I actually add one
more thing where I Cold Spring Harbor
teaches a course on single-cell
measurements and they do this every year
you can probably look up and see it it's
it's tends to be taught in June or July
and there's a unit of that course that's
only a few days long the course is
actually two weeks that is single cell
mass spectrometry and several people
from my group dr. Elena Romanov and dr.
Stassi Erbakan will show up and teach
that course to 2025 people every year
and they learn the isolation and the
other approaches how to make this work
and so there you know that's one example
of a way to learn this and we have one
more question which is more informative
single-cell transcriptomics or
metabolomics yes sir
that's a great question it depends on
the question you're looking so obviously
in terms of the omics transcriptomics
right now has the most commercial ways
the most ways to get information and
study cells and so there's the most
manuscripts on it it's been around a
little longer and there's the most
informatics ways of going through the
data
and so in some ways it's the most
informative now because if you were to
do single-cell transcriptomics you can
immediately compare your data to this
existing body of information single-cell
metabolomic s-- though gives you more of
an instantaneous snapshot of this of the
cell state the metabolomic Styria
environment do you think about lipids a
lot of the lipids are not made based on
the transcripts or the proteins within
the cell they're made based on what the
liver was doing somewhere far away and
then it transport those molecules and so
the single-cell transcriptomics is not
really encoding the lipids in a cell you
would have to know more information and
so it's sort of depending on what you're
looking at today easier to do
transcriptomics i think long term
single-cell metabolomic s-- will offer
critical information perhaps more
information than the transcripts well
i'd like to once again thank doctors
ruler for his presentation i would also
like to thank labrys for making today's
educational webcast possible and before
we go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through January 2019
you will receive an email from Lawrence
letting you know when does web cast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's event that's
all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon goodbye